we're back with actor filmmaker and
extraordinary human being George Clooney
it's always the origin story is so
fascinating for how people become who
they are and in walks a mall yeah
the most yeah awake
smart
what did you think when you met her well
it's funny she was she came to the house
in Como with a friend of hers to visit
and immediately I was but the funniest
thing is Brian Lord my agent Paul Ryan
he just met a mall and some other thing
and she said yeah I'm going to go to
Como with a friend of mine and he said
and he called me up and he said there's
a girl coming to your house that you're
going to marry and I was like you're an
idiot you know that's not gonna happen
and then comes a mall and we we stayed
up all night talking and then oh really
I started writing her you wrote her a
bunch of letters like on pen and paper
yeah oh we still write letters
still write letters we leave them on the
pillow
this is not working out at all this
interview
[Laughter]
it's Romance so and then we and then I
went to London she was living in London
and I went to London to score a movie
and I thought if you're ever going to
impress anybody it's at Abbey Road with
150 piece Orchestra there and I called
her up and said you want to come see a
visit over at Abbey Road and she's like
yeah I'm at a meeting uh at the Muslim
Brotherhood right now and I'll come
right over because she was in the middle
of trying to redo a constitution for uh
you know for the Egyptians
her life and my life are very different
I'll say that can I ask what the
proposal was like it's a disaster really
yeah I I planned it out I'm
not I've got
I've got a playlist with my aunt
Rosemary singing Rosemary Clooney
[Applause]
and I'm gonna I'm gonna give her the
ring right at the song why shouldn't I
which is why shouldn't I take a chance
when romance passes by it's a great song
so I've got it all planned out I've got
the ring and a little drawer behind her
I made dinner and we've only been dating
for about six months and I've got the
ring in the box and you know the song
starts you know we've been having dinner
and the song starts and I go you know I
think there's a lighter because I like
to re-light the candle which I blew out
you know re-light the candle I think
there's a lighter in that little box
behind and she kind of pulls this thing
out this little drawer and there's this
diamond ring in there and she looks at
it and she's like
there's a ring in there like
like somebody left a ring there years
ago you know and I'm like on my knee
like
[Music]
and and so now the song is playing and
she's and I go no I wanna you know I
want you to be my wife and I'm on my
knee I do this stuff and I we know
exactly how long it took because of the
playlist that goes on so she doesn't say
yes until this horrible song called
goody goody you know which is about like
so you met someone who else who set you
on your right goody goody you put it on
the playlist but yeah yeah but that was
supposed to be later right when we're
dancing
and she's just sitting here like going
oh my God oh my God and I literally said
listen I really would like to marry you
but I also am not young and I've been on
my knee now
[Laughter]
and I could like lose a hip
you know in the car and then she goes oh
yes and then we uh and it said yes thank
God
[Applause]
so he pulled it off
and now I have twins
yeah I mean oh my goodness that wasn't
part of the plan I want to say yeah
because her sister has twins too oh
really oh so there's twins in her
bloodline and family I went we went to
that you know you do that thing like at
12 weeks where they go there's the kid
look at the picture of the kid and I was
like yeah there it is there is because
it's a boy it's a boy and then he goes I
had a girl that was like what
it was such a disaster I was like are
you kidding me now it's the greatest
thing in the world I was terrified then
how so well because doubling down well
it was
56 years old and that just sounded
terrifying to me it's so funny I'm 47
I'll be 48 it sounds so young now to me
it's just because we're there well
here's what happens so is there anybody
here very young like because when I was
like oh you guys right there okay so now
you'll understand this when I was very
young 20. oh God I would hear someone
died at 60 and I think well they lived a
good life yeah
right me too you ready right
that they're shaking their heads yes
100 those two are trying to plant me in
the grave right now
I'm watching you
[Music]